the new york knicks are expected to be  punished for an early jalen brunson  agreement but there are two questions  here was brunson in the knicks a done  deal before free agency officially  opened  probably but is it against the tampering  rule this is where it gets a little  tricky let's look at the family trick  rick brunson jalen brunson's father was  recently hired as a knicks assistant  coach so we have that leon rose the  knicks president is very close family  friends with the brunson family so we  have that layer as well in addition sam  road leon rose's son is also liam  brunson's agent so we have this whole  family family friend ordeal going on  they're gonna talk their family so the  mavericks are pissed off from this whole  family situation going on but they're  also rattled because new york executive  william wesley was sitting courtside at  the first round game between the mavs  and the jazz this past season so again  sketchy yeah  against the rules  i don't know